at just nine years old Caitlin Melendez
has endured the worst of humanity at
Zion Lutheran Church in our Posse she
gets the comfort she needs just days ago
she was with her grandfather and his
wife as the gunman opened fire they were
at the checkout with their basketball
and your dad protected them yes he
jumped in front and pushed them
underneath the chair and shielded them
they walk out of their safe because of
him David Johnson had just turned 63 his
daughter recalls a panicked phone call
as the bullets rang out those screams
will stay with me her cries because I
wasn't there and she was asking for me
and asking when I was going to pick her
up and she just wanted to go home and
days were hot me for the rest of my days
and I know my mom my mom will say she
will remember that I just can't believe
those are gonna be the last things that
she remembers of my dad what kind of man
was he your father the kindest silly
funny always smiling
jamling gentle very family-oriented
that's how he raised us how he was
raised very very family-oriented they
were always first this city is full of
grief but today it has something else to
contend with a presidential visit and
once some here don't welcome this isn't
an easy visit for the people of El Paso
or for the president as leader he's
expected to come and honor the dead but
he hasn't seen as a passive player in
this story and some directly blame him
for encouraging a culture of division in
this country there's evil in this world
we're not in heaven
Maddie Margo has a difficult line to
tread he is the president United States
it was his it was of his own personal
volition to come out here and I will try
to comport myself as the representative
of the office of mayor we said Sunday
night at our at our services that our
interdenominational services that we
were going to confront Hey with love and
I'm going to take that to heart like so
many here he's haunted by what he's seen
and heard oh Sunday I was in the
hospital with visiting a little ten
month old little boy whose mother had
died protecting him and while we were
there his his grandfather was notified
that his son the father had died and
that was really what got me but then the
flip was we left there and we went to a
blood service and there are people who
had been there for seven hours waiting
to give blood and didn't care how long
it took they were going to give that's
El Paso and that's where I want people
to understand that tell pastor
the White House says the president wants
to grieve and console the community but
it will be a tricky path to navigate and
no one wants to feel any more anger than
they already do Cordelia Lynch Sky News
El Paso Texas